SPEAKER: With almost 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see "Google's
Vision for a Safer Web,"
then stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Over the past year,
we've seen amazing growth
from large and small
companies who are embracing
the web for productivity.
This means coworkers
are relying on the web
more and more for things
like collaboration,
remote working, and the
cloud-based services that
help them accomplish
their goals each day.
Sadly, attackers are
following this trend as well
and getting more creative.
We've seen more
attacks each year
and more variety in
the kinds of attacks.
Completely new attacks
are appearing as well.
Most of these attempt to gain
control of high-value accounts
so the attacker can use the
credentials for their own
purposes, which means
that the defense--
that's probably you--
needs new strategies too.
And Google is here to help.
We've been rolling out more
tools and features to Chrome
to help secure your
company's resources
and keep your employees safe.
At Google, we're very familiar
with these kinds of attacks.
We see over 6,000 instances
of unwanted software attacks
each minute, targeting
over 3 billion devices
around the world.
And thanks to our
Safe Browsing tools,
we can learn from these
attacks and recognize
new vulnerabilities
automatically.
And here's the best part--
your IT administrator can
get access to the same tools
and capabilities
through Chrome policies,
letting them see what
warnings were circumvented
and what common sites are
attack vectors on your domain.
To keep your passwords
safe, you can
use Password Alert,
which can notify admins
when an internal
password has accidentally
been used for an external site.
This helps fight phishing
and password-sharing
vulnerabilities.
But security isn't
just a one-way street.
Starting with Chrome
68, non-HTTPS websites
will be identified
as "not secure,"
helping us create a web that's
safer from eavesdropping.
Even with strong web encryption,
new vectors keep emerging.
With Spectre and Meltdown, we
saw machines around the world
suddenly at risk.
We reduced the ability
for malicious code
to spread with sandboxing.
Originally, we built
Chrome with tab sandboxing,
which prevents tabs from
interfering with each other.
Now with site isolation,
different sites in one tab
cannot affect each
other or leak data.
Thanks for watching.
You can see a link to the full
talk in the description below.
Subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more Next Rewind
videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]